like phil jackson back from the  70s knicks being the team photographer  that happened to you they won the  championship he was hurt and wound up  being the photographer  [Applause]  i know the pacers wish he would take up  photography full-time  29 other teams would by the way the  buck's largest margin of victory ever  59 points happened way back in 1978  leading scorer for the bucks that night  was ernie grunfeld with 27 points  they beat detroit 143 to 84. this is  where we're at this telecast has given  the largest margin of victories in  franchise history is the milwaukee bucks  have been sensational  now there's a photographer who's not  even taking pictures  he's texting on his phone  right he's done  he's allowed a little break  [Applause]  he's faking it because he knows he's on  tv right now